and right all of a sudden
philly the eagles have found a
quarterback let's hear from their head
coach on their spark that they just
found in order to go beat new orleans
here was coach peterson after the win
after going through the film and really
looking back even to last week and in
the preparation and everything
um i'm gonna i'm gonna continue with
jalen uh this week uh as as the starter
uh can i follow up on that real quick um
yesterday during your press conference
it sounded like uh
you chose your words a little carefully
when it came to either praising jalen or
and i was wondering
did you weigh you know carson's feelings
on that or was it also part of it you
know you don't want to put too much
pressure on this kid who just went out
and performed for you uh going down the
road yeah you know i i was thinking of a
lot of things quite honestly i was
thinking the carson but i was thinking
about the rest of the team and how the
rest of the team played you know in the
game and and jalen did after looking at
the film again today i mean jalen played
well i mean he was a big part of
you know the success we had on offense
and obviously helping us win that
football game but
there were a lot of other great
individual performances on both sides of
the ball right i i i think of miles
sanders i think
you know josh sweat and javon hargrave
and you know fletcher cox had a big game
big sack we had two defensive takeaways
in the game you know so there were there
were a lot of positives coming out of
the football game and i just didn't want
to say hey it was all about one guy
because you know you guys know me and my
answers and
i've always been about the team and and
really that was a team win yesterday
i'll tell you this jack um doug peterson
was absolutely wrong it was about jalen
hurts and he came in provided him a
spark but you know the interesting thing
about it listening to miles sanders he
said not only did he give him a spark
but he provided leadership and that's
something that they were missing
leadership at the quarterback position
and you know when you listen to doug
peterson yesterday and it's like okay
why is it so hard for you to come out
and say that jalen hurts played a great
game he played a great game and remember
why
this this is the thing that really
irritated me because for weeks you know
i said hey the saints are the number one
defense they're the top defense in the
league and everybody else started saying
the saints the saints defense this guy a
rookie quarterback came off the bench i
mean came in started and and played
tremendous against the best defense in
the national football league and i just
don't understand why it's so hard for
doug peterson just to come out and flat
and say that and yeah all these guys
made other plays but it was because of
their confidence in jalen hurts jack
i think he's still trying to manage the
quarterback room a little bit you know i
think after all those years with being
around carson wentz and and wentz being
the man at quarterback he's probably
trying to still keep him engaged but
there's no question that this was this
was a legitimate spark and the vast
majority of it came on the ground from
hurts there's one throw in particular
really stands out in my mind which was
the touchdown throw where he gets just
crushed quan alexander just absolutely
lays into him
but hurt steps into the throw and puts a
perfect back shoulder touchdown to
al-shawn jeffrey while taking a big shot
but the vast majority of that game was
hertz and he was scrambling at times
where he really didn't need to scramble
but that's something you see with young
quarterbacks and he was running right a
lot and that's something you see with
young quarterbacks but there there were
moments in that game where it had some
taste and pill effect to it if you will
where he would take off and it was a
power running scheme
his speed was more than the saints
defense thought it was but i really was
shocked that the new orleans defense was
not forcing him to throw i mean they
were giving him some wide open running
lanes and that seemed to be exactly what
hertz was looking for and they really
didn't adjust to it throughout the
course of the game over 100 rushing
yards that's that's how philly got a win
yeah i thought doug peterson did a good
job of going to what you know what's
comfortable to jalen hurts and that was
the rpos the same thing that nick foles
and they end up winning that
championship the super bowl all those
rpos and it just looked like jalen and
it was a lot of design bootlegs deep
getting outside the pocket whether it's
to the right side whether it was to the
left side to really help that offensive
line and that's what i saw the offensive
line they actually played pretty well if
you look at the tape you go back and
watch the tape they they gave him an
opportunity to drop back and pass the
ball run and um i was just so happy for
this young man because he's he's gone
through so much in his college career he
comes in he's done everything you've
asked him to do he's supported carson
wentz he's been humble he's worked his
tail off he understands exactly what's
going on as far as the x's and o's and i
couldn't be more proud of jalen hurts
for what he accomplished yesterday
i i agree with you and i thought it was
fitting that it happened against new
orleans because in large part i think
the reason that he was drafted was
because of the success of a guy like
taysom hill i really do the reason he
became a second round pick was because
and i think you know disrespectfully
probably people said oh he's a running
quarterback he's going to do the same
thing that's taysom is going to do well
we've seen that taste them is a throwing
quarterback too and we've seen that
hurts is a throwing quarterback too but
they also have that power running game
element to them and a leadership element
both of them have and you're seeing all
that come to fruition let's hear from
miles sanders on their quarterback and
what kind of a guy he is within that
locker room there in philly
he played awesome man uh
the tape shows for himself uh you know
he's so confident
and and so like he's a natural leader
and
you know we just needed that he gave us
that spark starting from last week but
uh
i mean y'all seen it all i think we
played a whole four total uh a total of
four quarters today and i think we look
like a complete team
uh minus the penalty we gotta clean that
up but overall i think i think this
whole team did a hell of a job
see
let me tell you it doesn't necessarily
have to come from the head coach but it
comes from those players in the locker
room and they listen they've been with
around carson wentz they know how he
operates and now they know how jalen
hurts operates and trust me he would not
come out and say the type of things that
he said about jalen hurts if it weren't
true i like miles sanders i think he's a
really good young back if he stays
healthy they have a chance and i'm not
saying they have a chance this year but
you look at zach urge dallas garden he's
got two big reliable targets that he can
throw the ball to you saw the back show
the fade that all sean jeffrey caught
and you just saw us you just felt a
sense of urgency and these guys playing
to the potential and it you go back and
you watch old tape of carson and you
just see him patting the ball holding it
holding it was like get sacked strip
sack and all of a sudden you saw jalen
hurts he's back there he's got composure
he's poised he sees everything if he
feels uncomfortable then you see the
athleticism you see the speed outside
the pocket and it just seemed like the
saints they weren't ready dennis allen
did not have his defense ready for what
jalen hurts brought um to the offense
and
it was just like mind-boggling but i was
really happy for the young man he played
extremely well jack
what does it do for the philly defense
i'm thinking about a couple of moments
in that game where hertz took off and
ran for a first down and you saw the
sideline on film just go nuts like all
the defenders that were standing over
there watching the game going oh this is
not wince anymore there's something
happening for us offensively what does
that do to the energy of a defense
standing over there realizing we may
have something coming in here at the
quarterback possession great question
great question jack it just sparks you
because they're so used and i played i
tell you man i played on number one
defense and i had the worst offense in
the national football league in 1998 and
it's it was just so discouraging every
time you would go out there you would
get three and out you would you would
get get the ball back to the offense and
they couldn't do anything with it and
it's like so frustrating time and time
again eventually throughout the game it
wears you down it discourages you and
then before you know it guys are
quitting guys are making business
decisions they don't want to hit guys
they're protecting their bodies so when
you have a guy out there running and
he's getting hit and he's trying to pick
up those extra yards it pumps you up it
gets you fired up because you know you
have a legitimate chance and you if i'm
fletcher cox i'm looking at all these
guys i'm saying look we have the talent
on defense if the offense just gives us
just a little something just give us a
little glimpse of hope we're gonna be
okay and it just fires you up and you
saw that you saw the energy that jalen
hurts and i i tell you like people
thought i was crazy i you and i said
play jalen hurts and they thought i was
absolutely crazy but i knew that this
guy would come in you know with the
level of maturity and humility that he
has and i knew he would ball out now
can he do it the next month of the
season we
will see but i do believe that he he
will continue to get better as he gets
more reps
well the topic of an offensive spark the
buffalo bills the game of the week
sunday night football bills steelers i
got you know i got some calls on the way
out rodney you know bill's mafia they
were tugging at my shirt on the way out
of the stadium going you got to talk to
rodney tomorrow about his pick because i
know you did go with the steelers
i want to give you a chance right now to
address all of the fans of which there
are many that are chirping one rodney
harrison
first of all i
if if the fans watch the show and i know
they do
football night in america i've given
buffalo nothing but props the last few
weeks i've talked about leslie frazier
being more um dynamic and aggressive
with his play calling i've said earlier
this year about the two safeties the um
of jordan poyer and micah hyde two of
the best safeties in the league i've
talked about their run game i mean i
don't know what else positive i could
say about the buffalo bills but i tell
you this because they trolled me they
said good morning i looked at twitter
this morning at five a.m they said good
morning everybody except rodney harrison
and it's funny because
i just so happened to bring i just so
happened to bring my super bowl rings
you know to connecticut to do the show
and
i got two super bowl rings back to back
is that so has buffalo ever won a super
bowl
i think i don't know i'm just saying
straight if my memory serves me right oh
i don't remember
from 91 92 93 and 94 they lost four in a
row right
so buffalo that's right rob buffalo
bills fans buffalo bills fans leave me
alone okay i've showed you nothing but
love this year i thought mike tomlin
would have those guys ready i thought
they would come out and play i picked
the wrong pick but at the end of the day
if you want to count super bowl rings i
think i got you buffalo
i actually thought it was a it was a
bold pick but not by no means a dumb
pick and without that johnson pick six
to end the half that looked like one of
those games where everyone's real hot on
buffalo and they are the trending team
they're playing better december football
all of the points they're healthier all
of the points were there on the table
but mike tomlin has a way i mean even
last year without ben rossberg when
eight games i mean he always has a way
of rallying his guys i think i really
think the difference in last night's
game was that this just wasn't a normal
stretch for the steelers it had it been
a normal stretch where it was a sunday
to sunday to sunday they had played 12
games or excuse me in 12 days they had
played three games and they had been
banged up throughout i mean they just
have lost so many defenders they're
without hayden uh they're without devin
bush they're without dupree there are
out so many offensive linemen that were
following last night it's just a beat up
football team so i think for them to try
to rally right now it just was hard
given that they don't have the same
amount of bodies there and then when big
ben made that mistake and they're
playing from behind
it just was not in the cards and in the
second half of that game stefan diggs
took over that steelers secondary he was
there was nobody nobody in sight that
could cover stefan diggs and josh
allen's proven that he's at the top of
the league playing the quarterback
position right now
and josh allen is a real deal he sees
the entire field and what i like about
him is he's that inspirational leader
he's a tough guy and he celebrates with
his team and he's humble and he works
hard and he's a normal guy he's just one
of the guys it's not like it's josh
allen up here and it's everybody else
over here he's involved with his
offensive line with his wide receivers
with his running backs i just love what
um what he's been able to do you talk
about stephon diggs well i have a vote
and he definitely has my all pro vote
definitely because he's been outstanding
this year um i thought he was gonna have
about eight receptions i think he had
ten and i knew that he was gonna have a
big night last night and he's just he
works so hard he's so tough people want
to say that he has a bad attitude the
guy wants to win and he's gonna hold you
accountable
i like what buffalo's doing they look
and they look different on defense i
love the aggressive mindset by defensive
coordinator leslie frazier um and he had
a great game plan they set on all the
routes they forced ben they they said
okay man we're going we gonna try you
we're gonna force you to throw the ball
down the field and he just didn't have a
lot of success doing that
in josh island this offseason accuracy
was the knock he's always had the big
arm but they kept continuing to knock
over accuracy and accuracy was
ultimately translating to completion
percentage he just wasn't completing
many easy passes and he was looking down
the field had a little brett favre to
him a little cowboy to him when he
entered into the league
and he's sort of been coached out of
that he's kind of gone far too like
breezed or brady he's trying to pull
some of that out but he still keeps a
little of that ability to scramble
around and throw a missile i mean he
just has a rare arm but he had his whole
throwing motion digitally mapped this
offseason digitally map is what they
call it 15 cameras they put around him
and he said the feedback that he got he
said you just go out there and throw and
then they shoot you this feedback the
feedback he got was that you are using
your hips less than all 20 quarterbacks
that we just digitally mapped your hips
are not a part of your throwing motion
whatsoever so while you have the
greatest miles per hour of all the guys
that we just went in here and monitored
you're not using the most powerful part
of your body when you're throwing the
football and so he said i'm gonna try it
and he started to slowly try this whole
process and he's like i was worse than i
was like i'm starting missing throws
that i was hitting before and i almost
quit on it it makes me think a little
bit of like when you get a golf lesson
and you go play
worse than you were before your lesson
and then you throw it out you know what
i'm saying and you throw it out and he's
like i was this close to throwing it out
and then i went and i watched and talked
to aaron rodgers and aaron rodgers has
this little left foot his front foot his
left foot has this little crow hop just
this little opening and that's what
allows his hips to open up and he said
as soon as he saw rogers he went back
out to the practice field started trying
it and bulmeck clicked and ever since
then
i mean this is this is he's in the mvp
race he's top three in the mvp race
right now and the completions and all of
the easy stuff it's happening he's a
different quarterback each year but you
know who jack is the probably the most
valuable player on their team it's
offensive coordinator brian dabal he was
with me in um in new england and the job
that he's doing just the comfort level
the way he's spreading the ball around
the way he's making a priority to allow
um stefan diggs to shine um
incorporating the run game getting the
ball to everyone and just the way their
offense is complementing their defense
and special teams and
i just give i just give brian dave all a
lot of props a lot of credit because i
mean to get josh allen who was a wild
child we knew that he had all the talent
and ability in the world but to get him
kind of honed in and focused and not so
erratic
i mean he's been tremendous he really
has and you know nobody's really
mentioned his name as a possible head
coach candidate but
i would say hey you need to probably
start looking at him and the work that
he's done with this young quarterback
i think you have to because he's what
everybody's trying to do right now is
develop a young quarterback over the
course of a two or three year span
that's about all you get as a coach if
you're not winning by then it's like
okay we got to look for the next guy and
who's proven that they could do that
better than dable
who has proven that better i
if you can think of somebody i'd like to
hear it uh he has been so impressive and
then cole beasley is another name that
since he's come over from from the
cowboys he really has just given him a
ton of comfort i mean he's
some slot receivers understand where
those holes in the zone are sometimes
it's not all about going full speed it's
about sort of shuffling your feet and
just finding that opening
and alan's developed a trust that he is
going to be a safety valve and i think
it's allowing him to look down the field
but then come back down through his
reeds because he always knows he can
just check it to beasley and bail him
out
and that's probably back to your point
is just dable coaching that confidence
into him
yeah and just the patience that he's
shown and that's what you see cole
beasley he's outstanding and when the
cowboys allowed him to walk i'm like are
you kidding me he might be your best
player or most reliable um target out
there but um yeah i'm just really um
proud of what josh allen did and just
how well he played and his continued
progress
yeah and you know what else he has a
little bit of and maybe it's just
because they were playing against the
steelers and so you watch the steelers
then you watch big ben and then you
watch allen you sort of go back and
forth between the two of them when
you're getting ready for the game
he has this little you know big ben over
the course of his career has really had
that pump fake right he kills defenses
when he does the full body pump fake and
then he comes right back and then he
goes left and everyone's like the whole
defense already moved five steps that
way and then he throws the ball back
that direction alan got richard sherman
with this little shoulder shimmy shake
last week and then through the touchdown
to uh to davis down the sideline and he
did the exact same thing on sunday night
football
and i asked him about it when we did the
interview this week and he said on the
sherman play
he was he was looking at sherman going i
know for this is pre-snap i know for a
fact that if i even just look into the
flat that i can draw because sherman's
always reading the eyes right he said i
know if i even just give him just the
slightest look and all it took was just
that that he'll bite on it he said i saw
the play happen before it happened and
that to me is the difference between a
first year quarterback and a third year
quarterback especially when they have a
great coach like we're talking about how
about for the pittsburgh steelers where
do they go from here rodney what what's
the biggest issue that you see with this
team are they cooked with all these
injuries or is there still a little bit
of fight i mean where are you where do
you see them going two losses in a row
now
well they got to get healthy i mean
that's the most important thing they got
to try to find a way to just fend off at
the end of the season and get and get
guys healthy but also you know when you
have guys that have been injured these
guys get an opportunity to play they're
just going to have to catch back up and
mike tomlin is going to have to take
some of the pressure off of ben and he's
going to have to try to figure out a way
and that's his job as a head coach is to
try to figure out a way with his
offensive coordinator to try to run the
ball even if it's quick passes to the
flat to the running back those are kind
of like elevated run up run plays but
they're gonna have to find a way where
it's not all been uh big ben dropping
back hitting four or five yard routes
and then you know and then eventually
like you talked about pump faking and
taking shots down the field they have to
have a little bit more balance and they
have to start catching the ball like the
ball is in your hands you got to start
catching the ball eric ebron and deontay
johnson of those guys you got to be able
to catch the football like mike thomas
said those are routine plays that they
need to make
they are and but when he said the whole
thing about you know catch the ball or
find somebody that will i
i get it but i i don't know there's some
there's something about the receiver
position that is it's a very mental
thing too you know and when you're wide
open and you've caught that ball you
maybe you catch that ball at the pro
level probably 99 out of 100 times but
when your head coach kind of puts you on
media blasts like that in front of the
whole world everybody's talking about
that quote and then deontay johnson's
wide open and he catches that thing 99
out of 100 times i just don't know with
that position in particular it's a
little like a quarterback it's like do
you really want to get inside of their
head like that and it appears like he
either got back inside of their head or
these receivers for pittsburgh or just
forgot how to catch the ball i have no
idea what's going on with them
i have no idea all right let's get into
the kansas city chiefs let's keep it on
these struggling offenses it's funny
because it was like the chiefs looked
unstoppable pittsburgh looked
unstoppable now for back to back weeks i
understand that they've won the games
but kansas city they struggled against
denver offensively and they struggled
against miami yesterday reason for
concern there in kc what'd you think of
the picks coming out of my homes as well
man you know i think i think we have
such an elevated um
just
opinion of you know
mahomes and how i mean i think we we
actually sometimes i think he should go
out there and play perfect football and
that's just not the case i mean you got
to understand these are the champs so
every week they play they're going to
get a team's very best shot
and
to me it's not the fact that he threw
interceptions but the fact that when he
threw the interceptions they were still
able to come back but when i look at the
mommy dolphins i was actually really
proud of the miami dolphins because
through it all through all the ups and
downs and them missing players and them
losing one on their starting wide
receiver devonte parker not having some
linebackers some veteran linebackers
because everything they did
um brian flores did this off season was
based on trying to beat the kansas city
chiefs or to compete against the kansas
city chiefs it wasn't to necessarily
beat the patriots or the buffalo bills
because brian flores know that he has um
championship aspirations so
if if i'm brian i'm actually proud of my
group we were underman we still fought
we clawed and we know that we can play
against anybody and you look at you look
at kansas city they're flat out loaded
you take away tyreek hill you got travis
kelsey catching balls and then you have
sammy watkins you got the running back
it's just they have so many weapons man
and no matter how poorly they play you
still gotta score 27 30 points to beat
them and that's that's the crazy thing
about it
that's it watkins got going yesterday
michael hardman had a huge play he was a
punt return yesterday for a touchdown
and he's the luxury pick he was the pick
that they took
and you know it was it was just in case
that tyreek hill is not going to be able
to be a part of the chiefs they pick
nicole hartman then they end up with
just two crazy speedsters so it's just
it's they're so overly wealthy with
playmakers i always like to go what
about robinson individually
of course of course i always like to go
through the interceptions individually
with my homes and so
i just don't think they're really
concerning plays the first one was a
fake screen to the left he spins around
and really the screen to tyreek to the
front side was wide open but the play
was to fake that screen and then flip
around like they always do the chiefs
always have some play nobody else has
seen and then to flip it around and
throw it to travis kelsey
and it just wasn't really there to
travis kelsey i think mahomes was
expecting that it would be wide open
probably like it typically is and it
just was tipped off his hands and falls
into the defender's hands another pick
that he had was a screen to elaire clyde
edwards elaire that you know he's a real
short dude and it just was a little bit
high he tipped it up and it was a layup
interception and then the third one was
the tyreek hill where tyree kill really
got spun around the wrong direction he
was looking the wrong way he was open he
was behind the defender but he really
had his head this way and then he tried
to flip back that way at the last second
uh and it just ended up being a pretty
you know pretty routine interception it
was a great play by the defender but it
was routine in the sense that tyrique
really could never find the football so
i don't think any of the interceptions
are trendy i don't think it's like
kansas city's falling apart i think they
were just unfortunate plays that all
happen to be in one game
i'll tell you this as a defensive guy
watching the tape every week on kansas
city it's amazing to me that he doesn't
throw two or three interceptions every
single week he gives defensive backs
opportunities and for whatever reason
because of the speed and because they
can't judge the ball the ball always
goes over their head and how many times
have we seen tyreek hill go over at his
size five nine or whatever he is five
ten jump over guys safeties that are six
feet tall like there's opportunities
against patrick mahomes and i always say
this when we have um kansas city i said
he's gonna give you two or three
opportunities the most important thing
is keep the ball in front of you and
catch it when it comes to you because
you're going to have opportunities so
you know you look at patrick mahomes i
don't worry about the interceptions
because he's such a risky quarterback
and he has a lot of confidence in his
guys and think about travis kelsey
even when he's covered and i thought
eric rowe safety eric rowe did a really
good job and he was right there on a lot
of contested but travis is just so big
and so athletic he runs such great
great routes and i've i've been
fortunate enough to defend a lot of
these all pro and
say hall of fame tight ends like tony
gonzalez and and shannon sharp and the
list goes on jason whitten and travis
kelsey is a better route runner than all
those guys he's fast he's athletic he's
like a big wide receiver and he has so
much wiggle and so much movement he's
incredible man and and i do believe that
when he's done he'll be a first ballot
hall of famer
yeah the other thing that miami did do
well is they they got pressure they got
pressure on patrick mahomes rarely do
you see him getting hit he was holding
the ball for a really long time and you
know i thought him sort of being able to
take off and do the run 15 yards
backwards and spin around and then throw
the ball 35 yards down the field i
didn't really think that was a stoppable
play
until i saw miami stop them they got it
for about a 25-yard sack
they really just did a nice job of like
the further backwards he ran they kept
the clamps on him the further he was
like we don't care we'll keep you right
there in between the hashes their
defenders did a great job how did they
do that so well how did they get
pressure on them that seems like some
flores belichick magic to me is that
what it was rod
well it's it's it's a lot of different
looks you know you have that seven-man
look and you're dropping defensive back
you're dropping um defensive linemen
you're blitzing certain guys you have
simulated pressures and things like that
but you gotta understand those guys are
hungry you know they've brian flores
he's had success against patrick mahomes
and andy reid so he knows how to play
him and patrick he's going to do
whatever he wants to do and like you
know 99 of guys you
say him and maybe deshaun watson you'll
tell him okay guys it's okay if you run
back 25 30 yards because you know they
have the skill and athleticism to do
that maybe cala murray too
but
everyone can't do that and you know that
as andy reid you got to live with some
of some of the good and some of the bad
when it comes to my homes but i don't
worry about kansas city kansas city to
me is the most complete team in afc and
nfc in the most complete team period and
um you got to come ready to play and i'm
just worried about miami and my biggest
concern i was talking to coach dungey is
hey they got to score 27 at 30 points if
they want to just be just be there with
the um kansas city chiefs because that's
what they do they score a lot of points
jack
yeah i agree with you and i think tua
has been encouraging in a lot of ways
flash has he's been encouraging i don't
know that he's necessarily been very
good yet i don't know that he's ready
for the bright lights yet i think this
miami defense is i think there's parts
of this miami team that is ready but
overall given the tua development it's
probably a team that's two or three
years away from something serious almost
like arizona i think the cardinals are a
similar boat where it's like let me get
it hold on hold on chad yeah jack go
ahead
you just said something i'm not just
gonna let you get away with that you
said they're two or three years away
absolutely not i believe i mean think
about what do you think miami's gonna do
something this year
let me finish please just think about
what they did this off season just think
about the improvements that they made
this off season through the draft
through getting free agencies um
drafting a quarterback the the thing
that he's going to focus on this
offseason is being able to have a run
game that's what they're missing because
tua is a game manager and there's
nothing wrong with being a game manager
and because they have a really good
defense and they got good special teams
but at the end of the day man
hey
you got to come with it and i think the
mommy dolphins are going to come with it
they're going to they're going to you
know be able to run the football i don't
think they're two or three years away i
mean they have a really good defense i
think that's the one thing they're
missing offensively is their ability to
run the football
your thoughts
i mean i thought i was really being
generous when i said two or three years
away i'm talking about making a deep
playoff run like i don't i don't think
it's a team that's bad i think they're
just sort of middle of the pack in terms
of the afc and i think it's a team with
potential to be top of the pack if tua
can develop and i don't really believe
tua is a game manager right now but from
a skill set standpoint if you can
develop what he has i don't think that
he will be a game manager do you think
his ceiling is a game manager rodney
like do you think in two or three years
he's not all that same player i just
think he'll be a lot better than he is
that's the point i'm making
no i don't i think he's a game manager
now but i think in the future as he gets
more confidence in his body and his
injuries and things like that i think he
i don't think he's gonna be a game
manager he wasn't a game manager when he
was at university alabama he was not a
game manager he was a guy that was
running using his legs spreading the
ball around and doing those things right
now he's trying to manage the game
because they don't want him to mess it
up and with that defense a lack of run
game and you have a game manager yeah it
limits what you can do offensively but
once they implement and they go and they
get that run game think if they can get
a guy like um what's his name travis atn
that type of speed where you can hand
the ball off and this guy has that type
of speed and explosion he can get 20 30
yards at any point in time that's going
to really take that safety out the box
that's going to open up i mean that's
going to add the safety in the box
that's going to open up the passing game
and i think that's when tour is going to
really shine but a young quarterback
like kim can't shine if they don't have
a run game
all right let's let's get to a team that
could use a game manager and the
washington football team they they kind
of had found one with alex smith alex
smith now injured i don't know what that
will be or look like dwayne haskins
comes back in probably more important
though to focus on what washington is
doing defensively back-to-back years
they've invested first-round draft picks
in the defensive linemen all of a sudden
they're starting to get pressure on
quarterbacks with ease are you a
believer in this washington team right
now
if you're asking me and i i asked mike
tarico asked me this question um i think
it was cup three weeks ago yeah i'm a
believer in the washington um football
team because of that
because of alex smith he's a game
manager you know he's not gonna mess it
up i think they have to get antonio
gibson back healthy i mean he is a stud
you talk about a top
seven eight back in this league top
eight back in this league i think
antonio gibson and i just like the what
they're doing flying around do i believe
in this team
as far as um haskins being a quarterback
i don't i don't believe in haskins i
think haskins is up and down i think
he's a a kid that's kind of immature
he's he's a little moody and
and i just
i think they're going to take a step
back with him i i hope alex smith
is healthy and i hope dwayne haskins
proved me wrong but i think ron rivera
has done a great job
with um what they're doing and they're
playing at a high level
defensively i'm with you i i'm fully
bought into what it is and offensively
it was enough with alex smith in there
and i don't think it's enough with
haskins in there he's kind of throwing
the ball recklessly all over the place
watching chase young play made me made
me think about this question i think
it's a good one for you rod if you had
to build a defense right now around a
young defensive lineman if you could
pick any of the young defensive lineman
to build your defense around you're the
defensive coordinator
who would you want who would be your top
pick right now if you could have any of
the bunch where would you go
well it's hard not to look at that kid
both out in san francisco he is an
absolute stud
um t.j watt is really really good i mean
he does everything he can drop in
coverage he stops to run but chase young
is just a special he's a freak kind of
reminds you of julius peppers just the
way he looks and how athletic he is and
how fast he is i mean the kid runs a
four or five at 280 pounds or whatever
he is he's just all muscle
excuse me but
him um yeah it'll probably be chase
young i mean just watching him play and
just the speed the athleticism the how
hungry how hungry they are getting after
the quarterback and he's that guy man
they're gonna have to deal with him for
a long time chase young is that dude
yeah and
totally and just the value that you
would get to on the rookie contract that
he's still on uh when he picked up that
fumble yesterday
man he's just like he's a man child out
there and started running down that
sideline there's no way somebody that
big can look that smooth he almost has
like that travis kelsey look to him when
he took off and runs like the stride is
just too perfect and you know i i keep
flashing back to what mike tomlin said
to him on that sideline clips like i i
hope i never lose enough games to draft
somebody that looks like you
he really does look like
like you just don't you do you don't see
many bodies that are that athletic in
the nfl if any i mean he is he is top
top tier like miles garrett aaron donald
you mentioned watt
i think i think he's right there in that
upper echelon of of young stars playing
the pass rusher position in the nfl
yeah no doubt about it i think he's
fantastic and he's going to contin we
have to understand he is a rookie he's a
young guy he hasn't even you know what
i'm saying he hasn't even been through a
full nfl season so he's going to
continue to work hard and just continue
to get better
yeah and we got to give some love to
montez sweat too because he's becoming a
stud there as well he slipped into the
first round but really becoming a good
player let's get to another pass rusher
how about assan reddick
five sacks
five sacks against the giants they
cannot block him at all and even he is
even doing a nice job of punching the
ball loose this is he almost seems like
single-handedly he took over that
football game uh and there really was no
offense from the giants but they
couldn't block him it didn't matter if
he lined up on the right left anywhere
in between reddick was just getting
after the passer yesterday you know the
thing too when you look at him he's kind
of that tweener guy he's not a big big
guy you know what i'm saying he's he's
taking on offense alignment and he's not
a huge guy but he is so fast he does a
great job with his hands and he has such
great body control where he knows how to
get to the quarterback and rush the
passer but when i looked at the giants i
thought they brought daniel jones back
too soon and i don't know if you saw
this but he just wasn't his himself he
couldn't run he couldn't move he was a
statue he's sitting there in a pocket
and if you take away his ability to move
and to run and to scramble then you
really negate what he does best and he's
a fantastic athlete he's fast he's got
good vision he's got a big arm but he
was just average because he couldn't
move
i think one of the biggest
misconceptions and you made this point
about the nfl about football in general
is that you need to be a big tall guy to
have success who's the best defender in
the nfl for the past handful of years
aaron donald
small guy i mean he's like 6-1 right
he's he has all the leverage all the
natural leverage in the world and i
think you see some of the same things
with reddick he's a first-round pick
2017 from temple but he ran like four or
five and he's crazy quick and he's short
six one he's that same size six six one
two thirty that same size as donald but
think about who he's going up against
all these six eight tackles that are 320
pounds trying to block this guy coming
off the edge they're like they just
can't get a hand on him and when he
gives them some of those shimmy shake
moves you just see them go whoa like
they're like trying to tackle a running
back or something do you believe in the
cardinals do you believe in the
cardinals do you believe in the
cardinals well they lost three straight
they lost three straight before this
game i mean i already made i made my
point in the last one about the
cardinals i think they're in a similar
position
as the miami dolphins i think they're
close i think they have a lot of young
pieces that are going to be something
and i i think in a year or two years
that they will be a great team and i
think right now they're a good team at
best
i would say
they're a solid team i don't know about
good they're just so up and down and
colin murray i still have my
reservations about him he's still a
young quarterback and at times i see the
level of frustration
so i would say they're a solid team i
wouldn't classify him as being a good
team i i would love to play the
cardinals nothing about the cardinals
would scare me if i had to play them in
the playoffs
i agree with that i agree with that and
the three-game losing streak showed a
lot of weaknesses and i think that you
saw a little kickback yesterday from
from the quarterback position from kyler
murray but also i think the giants are
really bad i i don't think the giants
are a good team at all and i think that
they're going to fall apart a little bit
down the stretch here come on man that's
not even fair to say hey wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait you
just got smoked by a team that you said
is quote quote-unquote solid yesterday i
mean how is that not a fair thing to say
bro brother i'm not i'm not i'm not all
i'm saying is this we go from the giants
and we you know we're talking about the
giants the last few weeks they're hot
you know they're doing a great job but
then all of a sudden they lose one game
and we saw the saints lose one game and
we saw you know other people lose games
and then all of a sudden they're just
they're just a terrible team joe judge
has done a great job with this team this
team doesn't have like a lot of talent
like offensively wayne garman is a solid
player he's getting him to play well the
wide receiver position i mean think
about evan ingram the level of talent
that he has
but
no catches i don't think he had any
receiving yards anything like that so i
wouldn't call the giants a bad team i
would say they had a bad day yesterday
and they're continuing to build but i
definitely wouldn't call them a bad team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports